these three features and they're kind of
like families of features these are
really the things that we want to focus
on when we'd want to get a visual sense
of what is a quadratic equation going to
look like when we draw its equivalent
parabola okay now I bet you can guess
what some of these are when you are you
know using the quadratic formula or on a
quadratic equation just up past it's
like just across let's go what time is
it mr. slate thank you
when you use the quadratic formula right
and you get two things out what are
those two things like suppose you put
the quadrate for me you put the numbers
in you got like three and negative two
what do those numbers actually signify
yeah on the graph yeah yet think think
it's good someone helped Rastan out
right there are two particular points
you get but what at one of the names
those are not just random points they've
got a special value like what about what
I just they're the X the X intercepts
right now we get the two if there are
two they usually are two x-intercepts
out but we're also graphing this so for
the sake of completeness it's not just
the x-intercepts you want it's also the
wider sense right so we're going to have
a look at these two things as it turns
out those are not the only useful
features to look for on a quadratic on a
parabola I should say when you graph a
quadratic equation for example sometimes
when you're drawing this in fact you
might want to draw a small one of these
next to where you've just written this
on certain equations quite a few of them
you go ahead you hear the quadratic
formula and then you get that problem
where you have a negative number two
under the square root because this is
the kind of shape that you get okay now
how many x-intercepts does this graph
have none so you like oh right by the
way fun fact you will always get a y
intercept always you can't not have a
y-intercept I will leave it as an
exercise to the reader why do you have
to always have a y-intercept but
sometimes have a think about it have a
think about it I want I want everyone
thank you string for your suggestion but
I don't want everyone to the file around
in their brain why would you always have
one of these but you don't necessarily
have these right now if you don't get
these
y-intercept you like okay I've got a
spot round to say that's not enough
information to work out where the graph
goes right so then you need extra little
bits of coordinates or things that can
help you so this next part is every
parabola is exactly a mirror image of
itself if you reflect it across the
right spot
right now when you've got something
that's symmetrical what do we call that
that place around which you reflect it
what it gets a name it's a it's you
could say light asymmetry but a more
precise word is the axis of symmetry
right so we can find the axis of
symmetry
we'll talk about how you do that in a
second right and once you find the axis
of symmetry so you're like oh cool this
is horizontally this is the middle of
the graph right what you then want to
work out is well how high am I up or
down on this on this line right it's
like a ladder you can climb up as far as
you like or down where am I on there
like where do I actually intersect with
that axis of symmetry and we have a name
for that spot where intersects starts
with a V
we call it the vertex right now there's
this other way that you can describe the
vertex it's not just the middle or the
like the bottom or the top
did you notice whether you've got a
parabola that's facing up or if you have
a parabola that's facing down like that
the vertex that middle spot is where the
parabola the coordinate equation it kind
of changes direction do you notice that
it was sort of like we have language for
this by the way do you remember we were
talking about functions before if I have
a look at this top parabola it's going
down all the way and so we use a single
word to say it's going down all the way
in that section it starts with the D
which is decreasing right so it's
decreasing in this little domain and
then it changes over it's it stops and
then it starts increasing it goes from
decreasing to increasing or of course it
could do vice-versa right it could go
increasing to decreasing in other words
it kind of like turns around right it
changes direction so we call this point
not just the vertex in this context it's
also the turning point because it
literally is the point at which the
equation or sorry I which the parabola
turns
round okay so in this context with
quadratics these end up being the same
thing we'll find the x and y intercepts
as much as we can sometimes you can't so
you need to search for the axis of
symmetry
once you've got that axis you can use it
to find the vertex so let's have a look
at how we do this for starters this will
be the color that I use right we already
established with the X intercepts you've
got some choices don't you write you can
factorize or you could whatever this--
we have we could once we make y equals 0
though for example if i had this right
once we make y equal 0 we then need to
factorize don't we and then we can just
read off the roots but suppose I got
something weird and gross like mmm done
right that's still gonna have fruits but
then I can't factorize nice and easy so
what's my alternative I should kind of
got a couple right I can use the now
just remember this is already an
equation what I'm going to use is the
formula right sorry we keep on doing
this but we want to be as precise as we
can with language so you know what
you're talking about when you do so
there's the quadratic formula for this
right that's kind of handy what about
the wine into since you find those right
so I should say y-intercept but yeah
that's it huh is interesting yeah we're
looking for the y-intercept we're
looking for the y-intercepts right hold
on so I've got some interesting
different parallel suggestions here
right
raster you said isn't it just this
number on the right that's what you said
yeah what do you guys think of that
because what our enzyme
[Music]
interesting so so I'm hearing a lot of
IDC you're also referring to I heard you
say this or you said this you also said
this right yes
right by the way in case you're curious
I'll tell this you saw this okay what
kind of shape would we get if we graphed
one of these what kind of shape we would
get how many times do I have to click
back we were getting we actually just
looked at them right yeah there we go
not too many this thing is such a
dilemma yeah there we go
right all of these objects these objects
are going to end up looking like this
these are interest to us in a different
context but they're not going to give us
parabolas right we want a power like two
to appear okay so I'm interested because
you sort of throw this idea but I'm not
sure what everyone thinks so I'm going
to do an experiment with you we had this
suggestion right that we want to find
the y-intercept it's just this number
here I'm gonna ask all of you I'm gonna
take a vote from all of you here's the
way this works okay you're gonna give me
a thumbs up if you think that wrastlin
is right you just read that number off
okay and that's the y-intercept and
you're gonna give me a thumbs down if
you disagree what you can't do is give
me no answer okay so you've you've all
right it's already been like 45 seconds
since rest and said that so I hope you
had some time to process thumbs up or
thumbs down I'm gonna wait until
everyone has their hand up in some way
whereas even down fighting himself
that's great okay
thumbs up or thumbs down I'm gonna wait
for everyone to have a have a vote
no no thumbs up or thumbs down thumbs up
or thumbs down it's a digital voting
system do you like that digits anyway
nevermind I'm still waiting I hold them
up I can't see I can't see
alright yeah hold them up you everyone
else this is yeah I actually want you to
have a look around at each other's
suggestions by the way
come on shame RV commit to something
hold it up so everyone else can see not
just you
okay what's your it's always your it
okay interesting what is that a Shawn
what is that it's a that's it down
that's it down that's it down okay
alright hands down